[Musique]
on a décidé de prolonger les vacances
sur le canal à dole et vous allez le
voir c'est très agréable
mais avant la balade corvée de ménage
sur le pont quatre bateaux vont partir
cette après midi
l'entreprise de location propose des
week end ou des vacances sur des bateaux
sans permis
elle est installée à dole depuis 1990 et
chaque été elle séduit des plaisanciers
du monde entier le tourisme mondial
attire de plus en plus de monde par
action par rapport aux camping caristes
c'est complètement différent
le repos c'est complètement différent et
être au fil de l'eau c'est complètement
reposant l'entreprise gère tout le port
de plaisance cet été près de 700 bateaux
ont jeté l'ancré ici daniel et myriam
viennent de suisse dole est la dernière
étape de leur croisière daf et steve
martin
c'est la première fois en dix ans que
nous faisons ça d'habitude nous sommes
camping caristes et pourquoi un bateau
cette fois pour faire quelque chose de
nouveau
moi je connaissais mais pour ma compagne
c'est une première elle n'avait jamais
fait ça et c'était comment elle a
survécu
[Rires]
les bateaux arbore les pavillons
allemands suisses et même néo zélandais
ce groupe d'amis fut l'hiver dans son
pays
ils naviguent tous les ans pendant trois
mois sur les canaux français et ils sont
charmés par l'ancienne capitale comtoise
c'est une ville très mignonne c'est
magnifique c'est un de nos endroits
préférés
les canaux passe dans les vieilles
partie des villes et c'est vraiment un
très bon moyen de passer des vacances
détendu et pendant ce temps là d'autres
plaisanciers prennent leur quartier ils
sont cinq et ils partent pour un
week-end prolongé entre amis d'abord
petite leçon de pilotage
aucun autre indicateur de bord savoir
s'il vous plaît à bâbord à tribord ok là
l'unique de l'allume-cigare 12 watch le
projecteur le groupe peut larguer les
amarres direction la saône vitesse de
croisière 5 km environ fabrice et
frédéric prennent les commandes
ils sont très vite à l'aise c'est très
agréable
1h03 de wes et des paysans se reposeront
tout et tout et c'est pour ce soir
tranquille
on allait en vigueur en mai pour amal à
la capitainerie
carola gère les locations et les
arrivées des bateaux en allemand en
anglais ou en français
elle accueille les plaisanciers depuis
17 ans pour elle la saison n'est pas
encore terminée
ça va continuer jusqu'au mi-octobre mi
octobre on va terminer la saison nichols
a via le port il va être terminé aussi
est vraiment fin octobre en coupe
l'électricité en couple aux essais
libres libère c'est terminé la saison
les vacances touchent à leur fin
le port c'est un peu vidé de ses
occupants certains plaisanciers vont
maintenant profiter de l'arrière-saison
pour naviguer avec encore plus de
tranquillité